before i go on i just want to say randy
newman
16 nominations he finally won
i'm so excited i forgot what i was
supposed to say so i'm going to just
move on but
congratulations randy wherever you are
right now
just wipe up when you're done
i had to have one for the evening come
on i've been very good this evening very
good
no i meant well-behaved
not good i meant well-behaved listen for
years men have
imitated john travolta's style they've
imitated his mannerisms his swagger and
his walk
and women have also imitated sharon
stone
when she wore a little black turtleneck
everybody wore a little black turtleneck
when she got her hair cut short
everybody got the hair cut short
and listen what woman hasn't wanted to
put her husband in a cage with a komodo
dragon honey
you know
just burning bridges everywhere i can
please welcome the magnificent sharon
stone and john travolta
the nominees for this year's best
foreign language film
come from five different countries on
three different continents
there's a film from norway
in the official language of norwegian
there's one from france with french
dialogue
israel from india and bosnia and one
from
argentina which are all the official
languages of los angeles
the nominees are
from france amelie jean-pierre jenae
from norway elling petterness
from india lagaan ashitash
gowariker bosnia
and herzegovina no man's land dennis
tanovic from argentina son of the bride
juan jose campanella
ah and the oscar goes to bosnia and
herzegovina
for no man's land accepting the award
the director dennis tanovic
this is the first academy award
nomination for bosnia-herzegovina
no man's land is about a bosnian and a
serbian soldier trapped together between
enemy lines
writer director composer danis tanovic
has filmed over 300 hours of footage
on the front lines of sarajevo
wow thank you
academy especially those who voted for
me
i have to thank to my producers
especially two men who started all this
cheddar caller who read a screenplay and
who followed me till today i have to
thank to my crew to my actors
one of them is two of them up here
i want to thank to united artists to
bingamri
who did a great great job in promoting
my film here
and thank you yes
i want to thank to my wife for being so
beautiful and good to me
and loving me and being patient and this
is for my country for bosnia thank you
ladies and gentlemen two-time academy
award winner
kevin spacey
thank you and good evening everyone
obviously none of us can look back on
this past year
without a deep sense of sorrow and grief
that has become a part of all of our
lives
traditionally at this point in the show
we pause to remember those members of
the film community who are no longer
with us
but this year since september 11th
we must stop this evening and mourn a
great deal more than that
would you all please rise and join me in
a moment of silence for every single
american hero
who gave his or her life on september
11.
you